[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales de la tnt
tout voici les titres de l'actualité
avec pour débuter le service national
universel 18 mille jeunes ont participé
à la première session du service pendant
douze jours reportage de vosges
télévision à suivre dans ce journal et
si vous ré parier votre moto vous même
c'est l'idée originale que propose un
atelier en ile de france grâce notamment
à des conseils d'experts la rédaction de
via 95 a mis les mains dans le cambouis
pour vous vous verrez et puis l'afrique
depuis limoges enfin d'édition la ville
met à l'honneur les plantes et végétaux
du continent africain dans le cadre de
son exposition couleurs d'afrique ouvert
et
c'était une promesse du candidat
emmanuel macron le service national
universel se développe un peu partout en
france les avis aux jeunes âgées entre
15 et 18 ans il a pour but de renforcer
la cohésion sociale en facilitant la
mixité est ce vraiment efficace
l'expérience dans les vosges abus sango
87 jeunes ont effectué leur s à nu
hélène le plat pour vosges télévision
ils pourront en témoigner plus tard j'ai
fait mon service pas un service
militaire mais un service national
universel à bussang 87 jeunes garçons et
filles de 15 à 17 ans ont intégré ce
dispositif
c'est en uniforme que durant 12 jours il
multiplie les ateliers civique culturels
sportifs comice il escalade sur les
pistes du larcenaire on est objectif
c'est d'améliorer et d'augmenter la
cohésion nationale la deuxième c'est le
mixage sociale les inciter à s'engager
dans des missions d'intérêt général les
stagiaires sont issus du grand est la
répartition a été fait pour garantir un
brassage social et dans le but de leur
permettre de découvrir d'autres
territoires la participation aux essais
nu et basé sur le volontariat c'est la
première année qu'une session est
organisée dans les vosges le début de
nouvelles expériences
[Applaudissements]
le côté chasse militaire il est plus
dans l'est dans le quotidien ou par
exemple on a une levée du drapeau avec
la marseillaise j'aimerais bien
réservistes dans l'armée de terre je me
plais bien sauf
sauf le rythme de sommeil une sorte de
rituel de passage le service national
universel est aussi une promesse du
candidat emmanuel macron lors de sa
campagne aux présidentielles il s'agit
de former des jeunes bien dans la
société dans laquelle les évolué et puis
ensuite selon leur volonté leur degré
d'implication dans la société ils
pourront peut-être s'investir plus ou
moins dans la vie publique par exemple
dans la vie sociale dans la vie
associative
le dispositif est appelée à se
généraliser à toute une classe d'âge
pour cette seconde édition 18000 ados se
sont portés volontaires 40000 pourraient
en bénéficier en france l'an prochain on
estime à terme que huit cent mille
jeunes pourraient faire leurs essais
nucléaires n'est pour un budget de 2000
euros par personne pour former de
nouveaux citoyens et vous l'avez entendu
dans ce reportage le service national
universel peut déboucher éventuellement
sur une carrière militaire
intéressons nous à présent à ce que l'on
appelle les réservistes ils sont des
milliers d'hommes et de femmes à être
volontaire pour soutenir l'armée en cas
de besoin quel est leur rôle précisément
mangane crocs pour la rédaction de tl7
la télévision de la loire est allé voir
pour vous
dans ce bureau de cellule de suivi de
crise trois personnes ce jour là ils
sont réservistes ce sont des soldats
d'appoint qui viennent renforcer les
armées 30 jours par an en moyenne et sur
la base du volontariat il faut vous me
le trépied pour ce soir impérativement
avant 17 heures au quai en cas de
catastrophes naturelles ou de tout autre
événement particulier dans notre
département de la loire les réservistes
sont activés le reste du temps ils se
forment notre
présence est effectivement dans 90% des
cas dédié à notre hôte aux entraînements
nous sommes comme une assurance dans le
milieu civil à savoir que ont hélas si
jamais ça va mal pleinement intégré
formés et entraînés pour assurer les
mêmes missions que leurs camarades
d'activ ces trois réservistes
volontaires sont tous issus du monde
civil je suis responsable technique dans
un lycée stéphanois ancien militaire
active est maintenant chef d'entreprise
dans le civil l'adjudant chef philippe
est parti plusieurs fois en opérations
extérieures c'est un ancien militaire
d'activ alors l'engagement est ancré en
lui ayant servi l'institution déjà
pendant 32 ans
pour moi il semblait logique de pouvoir
mettre à profit du monde civil et puis
la défense mes connaissances déjà
acquises à chacun son histoire chacun a
son domaine des spécialités après c'est
justement ce qui fait aussi la richesse
des réservistes c'est qu'on arrive de
deux mondes totalement différents la
place du réserviste est importante il ya
une complémentarité de compétences et
une connaissance du département le
commandant frédéric partage ainsi son
savoir faire tout en l'adaptant aux
attentes spécifiques de l'armée de terre
il ya un certain nombre de choses que je
maîtrise notamment la logistique ou les
travaux et ça serait tout à fait adaptée
à une situation ici dans les partenaires
ou ce n'est pas les chars russes que
l'on craint mais c'est tout un tas de
problèmes logistiques mais c'est surtout
aussi un rôle de commandement et de
coordination entre toutes les forces
de sécurité civile le lieutenant bernard
en dos quant à lui l'uniforme de marins
depuis qu'il a mis le pied dans
l'institution militaire c'était il ya
trente ans il ne l'a jamais plus quitté
leur à l'issue du service national donc
je suis revenu dans le monde civil et
puis quelque part je me suis rendu
compte qu'il me manquait quelque chose
cet esprit de corps c'est esprit de
camaraderie
dix sept réservistes servent les unités
militaires de la loire un réserviste
signé un contrat d'engagement pour une
durée de un à cinq ans
le portrait représente d'un papa et
d'une maman aurélie égale perrouault
sont les heureux parents de trois
enfants deux garçons mathis et nathan et
d'une petite fille léana celle ci est
atteinte du syndrome cardio faciaux
cutanée un syndrome rare et qui entraîne
notamment un retard de croissance et une
déficience intellectuelle un handicap
qui a évidemment bouleversé leur
parentalité un reportage d'eléonore si
nos quais de mélanie poker la rédaction
de tv 78 dans les ive et comme tous les
soirs à neauphle-le-vieux aurélie et
gaëlle perron accueillent leur fille qui
rentre de sa journée en institut léana
11 ans est handicapée elle est atteinte
du syndrome cardio faciaux cutanées
c'est un syndrome très rare en fait et
qui impacte à la fois dans sa peau son
coeur et
heureusement pour nous les anars que ça
soit au niveau cardiaque ou au niveau
cutané
n'a pas de problème particulier
par contre au niveau de la nourriture de
l'oralité c'est très compliqué
puisqu'elle est nourri par une sonde
déjà parents de matisse 15 ans aurélie
et gaëlle accueille des jumeaux en 2009
nathan et léana cette deuxième grossesse
change alors complètement la parentalité
du couple disons que avec avec son grand
frère
on avait entre guillemets nos habitudes
donc nous d'avoir des jumeaux c'est pas
quelque chose qui nous faisait forcément
peur
mais après forcément avec le handicap ça
remet tout en question et puis c'est des
nouvelles habitudes je pense que la
résilience est quelque chose d'important
pour un des parents d'enfants handicapés
parce qu'il faut savoir avancer avec
cette différence et construire la vie
différemment de celle des autres à la
naissance des jumeaux aurélie cesse de
travailler léana a besoin d'une
surveillance constante
hospitalisé pendant les premières années
de sa vie les médecins ne feront un
diagnostic qu'au bout de trois ans une
longue période de doute d'angoise et
même de culpabilité pour les parents ça
a été trois années très longue pour nous
en effet un peu en errance diagnostique
et
on essayait de comprendre la situation
parce qu'on avait une petite fille qui
ne s'alimentaient pas savoir que c'était
un syndrome non héréditaire en fait
c'est la faute à pas de chance voilà les
annales elle ce gène qui a muté passé le
choc et la culpabilité la force prend le
dessus après de longues recherches léana
est admise à 6 ans dans un institut
spécialisé prise en charge la journée la
petite rentrer le soir à la maison un
quotidien désormais bien rodée pour les
parents pour faire face aussi au
handicap de leur enfant aurélie et
gaëlle ont créé une association en 2015
nommé au fil de léana cela leur a permis
de rompre l isolement c'était très
important pour moi en fait de montrer le
handicap et de plus sentir en dehors la
société parce que pendant six années je
me suis considéré comme en dehors de la
société avec ma fille pas à créer du
lien autour de nous de bien social et
c'est vrai que ça nous a apporté une
force avec l'association la famille
c'est aussi découverte une passion
commune le sport entre course à pied et
vélo de quoi partager des moments hors
du quotidien
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
maintenant et si vous ré pariez vous
même votre moto quand celle ci est en
panne lancé il y a 6 mois un atelier
collaboratif située à argenteuil dans le
val d'oise mais tous les outils
nécessaires à disposition des clients
les propriétaires julien d'ostéo
williams gomez sont là pour les
conseiller il propose différentes
formules à l'image des salles de sport
explications de romain et u11 pour vient
95 sur place
bienvenue à la maison mécanique un
garage d'un nouveau genre où le
réparateur n'est autre que vous même
pour mathieu 21 ans c'est une première
outils en main l'étudiant en école de
commerce apprend à faire la révision de
sa bécane acquise il ya moins d'un an il
est supervisé de près par le
propriétaire d dieu julien d'offres
c'est cette partie là qui entretenait
avec le avec le dise et dès que tu vois
que tu es vraiment limite que tu as
garniture est vraiment arrivé sur fait
de la quête alors là je commence tout
juste là depuis quelques minutes mais ça
se passe déjà très bien puisque explique
déjà des aspects théoriques voire ou
regardé par rapport à ce qui est à faire
et après du coup je fais par moi même
puis quand j'ai des questions quand il
faut passer à la prochaine étape on
avance ensemble avancer ensemble c'est
précisément l'objectif de julien dost
pompier volontaire à cormeilles en
parisis le jeune homme de 21 ans
rencontre son futur associé en caserne
william gomez lui âgé de 28 ans
rapprocher par leur amour de la moto les
deux pompiers volontaires se lance en
novembre 2020 leur pari ouvrir une
seconde maison pour les motards
l'idée c'est qu'on les gens viennent ici
ils puissent dire qu'ils vont à la
maison et qu'ils se sentent comme chez
eux qu'ils fassent leurs mécaniques
comme ils le feraient dans leur garage
qui prennent un café comme ils le
feraient dans leur salon et que on passe
un bon moment dans un cadre dans un
cadre sympathique ici l avantage c'est
que les gens ont tout le matériel dont
ils ont besoin qui est à disposition
will i am et julien partage d'une
passion commune restaurer de vieilles
bécanes à l'instar de cette moto
abandonné sur laquelle il s'attelle sur
leur temps libre et le résultat final
vaut bien souvent le coup d'oeil ces
motos de type racer sont fièrement
exposée à l'entrée comme un gage de leur
expertise en force d'en réparer et d'en
préparer une première et une deuxième
dans nos garages sans forcément avoir du
team on s'est dit qu'il y avait un réel
besoin
dans la communauté des motards et qui
manquait de la place de l'outillage du
stockage et qu'il fallait qu'on essaye
de mettre au point un lieu vraiment
complet pour le motard pour pouvoir
justement faire des petits projets de
restauration mais au-delà de ça de
l'entretien courant et c'est comme ça
que s'est créé la maison mécanique à
l'instar des salles de sport les clients
ont le choix entre des formules allant
de 17 euros pour la location d'une heure
à plus de 80 euros par mois pour un
forfait de 90 heures sur les cinq pour
occuper certains sont plus à l'aise que
d'autres c'est notamment le cas de
matteo 19 ans qui vient régulièrement
depuis un mois des efforts qui ont fini
par payer puisque l'étudiant
tabernaciens est désormais capable
d'entretenir sa bécane comme un pro
c'est une économie déjà et puis pour les
connaissances personnelles c'est
toujours intéressant pour la culture
générale de savoir ce qu'on fait le plus
attention que moi je comprends ce que je
fais donc en plus grand qu'avant quoi
ouvert six jours sur sept l'atelier
propose aussi des cours de mécanique le
dimanche matin les deux biker
réfléchissent à mettre en place des
journées de prévention à la sécurité
direction la moselle où le département
abrite neuf fermes pédagogiques sur son
territoire celle ci propose aux jeunes
et aux moins jeunes de se familiariser à
la vie de la ferme à petit temps qu'un
les enfants peuvent notamment découvrir
les coulisses du quotidien d'un fermier
un reportage de jean mi longs pour moi
zèle télévision regarder
bonjour ben on a quatre petits fermiers
et fermières aujourd'hui dis donc ça va
vous avez pas trop froid non vous êtes
prêt pour la visite de la ferme
aujourd'hui deux familles sont venues
découvrir les coulisses de la ferme
premier arrêt pour le petit groupe les
tables les enfants dans les tables c'est
la même en des vaches
oui le fameux les vaches en tout
l'exploitation compte ici une
soixantaine de vaches en lactation qui
visiblement ce matin finiront le ventre
bien rempli et pour les enfants c'est
l'occasion d'en apprendre un peu plus
elle a des dents ou
[Musique]
au non non la bachelot elle a un
bourrelet mais à la fois du don en
ouvrons nos portes et main ça permet
aussi de casser cette image qu'on voit
parfois la télévision sur les fermes et
de dire ben justement venez on est
ouvert on vous accueille venez voir chez
nous comment ça se passe en général
quand ils arrivent au début séoul à la
sap sont pas bons les vaches et puis
quand ils repartent quand on demande à
qui veut être fermier ou fermière tout
le monde lève la main tout le monde est
content et ça nous fait plaisir et a us
mais il avant d'être un véritable
fermiers ou une véritable ferme hier il
ya une étape obligatoire à laquelle on
ne peut pas y échapper
la machine qui est devant vous les
enfants ça s'appelle un robot de traite
avec cette machine sept minutes
suffisent pour traire une seule bête
mais aujourd'hui pas question de céder
de la technologie regarde alors la bâche
pour lui dire que tu es là tu veux
appuyer sur ce petit bouton la voilà
hélas elle reçoit à manger ensuite pour
que la vache elle n'est pas peur tu mets
ta main ici tu lui dis bonjour et
ensuite après avec ta main tu vas
prendre le crayon
et tu appuies l'objectif surtout c'est
de faire participer les enfants au
maximum qu'ils se rendent compte que bat
pour avoir un bon repas bas il ya un
travail derrière il a travaillé la terre
il ya le soin des animaux et toutes ces
choses là font que bâle
on arrive à avoir un produit de qualité
lancé en 2003 le projet de ferme
pédagogique à son lot de succès
aujourd'hui le site accueille jusqu'à
2000 enfants et adultes chaque année et
a pris les traire les vaches et
dédaignant manger vache
donne aurait permis en maintenant
les traits des vaches et cetto d'équipé
euros pour terminer les enfants
partageront quelques moments d'intimité
d'abord avec les poules puis dans un
deuxième temps avec les chèvres toujours
enclin se faire dorloter
s'en suivront un goûter copieux et une
photo souvenir histoire d'immortaliser
la journée
des animaux encore dans ce grand jt des
territoires mais des animaux marins
chaque été le centre de soins de la
faune sauvage de calais prend en charge
des bébés veaux marins et pour aider au
financement des soins qui dure plusieurs
semaines avant un retour en milieu
naturel la ligue de protection des
animaux vient de lancer une opération de
parrainage caroline fichten pour la
rédaction de jouer aux tv la chaîne de
la voix du nord regarde et
lcl qu'un c'est le premier bébé veaux
marins de cette saison à être en soins
au centre de la faune sauvage de calais
arriver à tout juste 10 kg avec encore
le cordon ombilical
elle va se faire chouchouter le temps de
savoir se nourrir seul et de prendre du
poids la séparation mer petit et souvent
dus à un comportement inapproprié des
humains pas par méchanceté mais par
méconnaissance
parce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
phoques nes sur le sable donc c'est pas
étrange d'avoir un bébé phoque est seul
sur le sable puisque la maman elle va
chasser pour se nourrir et revenir pour
allaiter son petit ce qu'il faut c'est
rester respecter une distance de
sécurité notamment en l'occurrence dans
ces cas-là faut essayer de respecter au
moins deux à trois cents mètres s'il n'y
a pas de dérangement l'année la nature
est bien faite la maman va finir
d'allaiter son petit va l'emmener quand
il sera suffisamment grand pour lui
apprendre les modalités de sheth
chaque été au moment des naissances
plusieurs veaux marins rift ici et il
reste plusieurs semaines le temps d'être
soigné est suffisamment fort la lpa qui
gère ce centre cherche donc des parrains
et des marraines pour aider au
financement des soins à partir de 50
euros vous pouvez donc parrainer un
phoque à la clé vous assisterez à sont
relâchés dans son milieu naturel un beau
cadeau monsieur me disait au téléphone
moi bon les nouvelles voilà vous voulez
donner c'est bien mais je veux vraiment
assister à son rôle de lâcher je veux
vraiment la voir repartir en milieu
naturel c'est pour moi un moment magique
est important donc le plus important
pour moi voilà je pense qu'on est
effectivement se relâcher en milieu
naturel et le plus important pour les
parrains et marraines el kahaz peut être
parrainés donc mais d'autres vos marins
comme chaque été seront soignés ici
toutes les infos sont sur la page
facebook du centre de soins de la faune
sauvage lpa de calais
la rentrée maintenant c'est connu est
une période particulière pour les
parents comme pour les enfants elle peut
engendrer du stress et pour vous
détendre pourquoi ne pas essayer le yoga
en corse une professeure pauline k
qu'elle dit propose des séances d'hatha
yoga au bord de la plage presque les
pieds dans l'eau vous allez le voir
cette pratique traditionnelle de yoga
tout droit venus d'inde permet de calmer
et de détendre une méthode de relaxation
accessible aux sportifs et non sportifs
petits et grands propos recueillis par
la rédaction de gnt les pas aisée
pauline ceccaldi c'est un yoga où on
prend le temps de rester dans les
positions en moyenne je pratique entre
deux à trois heures par jour l'été qu'il
ya plus de monde dont plus de demande et
après l'hiver en pratique entre 4 et 5
heures par semaine on commence par de la
méditation dans le temps de se connecter
à son corps ensuite on commence avec des
salutation au soleil
c'est un enchaînement de position qui
permet au corps de se réveiller de
diffuser les énergies dans le corps
ensuite en pratique donc place la taille
au garrot vinyasa selon les séances et
on finit toujours par une méditation
un scan de tout le corps qui permet
vraiment de lâcher prise et de se
détendre après avoir sollicité son corps
c'est un bateau historique à marier en
martinique après 45 années en mer le
toumelin dessiner en 1971 par le
capitaine pierre grenet est en pleine
rénovation le voilier s'est vu attribuer
une dotation de 150 mille euros de la
part de la fondation du patrimoine après
la coke les bénévoles s'attaque à la
restauration des gréements jean-marc
carteron et marie tricot pour vyas atv
martinique sur place
toute l'équipe ses actifs pour redonner
aux trois mâts goélette de 28 mètres
cinquante son lustre des premiers jours
pour daniel chaque étape de la
rénovation est un hommage à son mari
pierre brunet à l'origine des plans du
tout blanc dont la repris les idées de
mon mari avec mon fils yoann et nous
avons créé un atelier chantier
d'insertion
d'hyper main si vous voulez d'enseigner
la polyvalence des métiers manuels du
nautisme l'apprentissage de ce savoir
faire est souvent exigeants parmi les
techniques nécessaires à sa rénovation
certaines restent inchangés depuis 1971
avant la mise en service du navire il
reste encore de nombreuses étapes les
premières étapes donc c'est donc la mise
à l'eau une fois que cette mise à l'eau
est fait là on va pouvoir engendrer
d'autres chantiers qui sont dans le dans
le programme de l'atelier chantier
d'insertion c'est à dire tout ce qui est
boiseries nous avons aussi un atelier
donc tout ce qui va concerner la
mécanique moteur principal ainsi que les
moteurs auxiliaires et puis le chantier
gréement ce sont là les grandes étapes
pour les prochains mois une fois sa
rénovation terminée ce voiliers de
tradition qui sillonnent les eaux
caribéennes depuis 30 ans continuera
d'accomplir son destin et ses nombreuses
missions le navire
naviguera avec des élèves de l'école
maritime de trinité de façon à ce qu'ils
obtiennent leur j'ouvre de validation au
revers de sa construction sur le
chantier naval de marseillan à sa
rénovation dans la marina du marin le
toumelin premier navire dans la caraïbe
classés monuments historiques fait la
fierté de ceux qui contribuent à sa
légende
il traversait la méditerranée et faire
le tour de l'afrique tout en restant à
limoges c'est possible depuis quelques
semaines la capitale de la porcelaine
par ces jardins des couleurs d'afrique
une exposition à découvrir dans les rues
de la ville jusqu'au 3 octobre le tour
de la flore africaine avec benjamin
delmas de 7 à limoges regarder
la mairie de limoges met à l'honneur la
biodiversité florale africaine c'est
culture son patrimoine au travers
plusieurs expositions et manifestations
organisées dans toute la ville c'est
dans ce cadre qu'un terrain vague de
2000 m² est transformé en paysage venus
d'ailleurs ou les dunes de sable
côtoient les plantes luxuriantes
d'afrique équatoriale un travail de
fourmi conçu par les agents des espaces
verts de la ville de l'image pour
reconstituer la biodiversité africaine
ce jardin a été créé et pensé par une
équipe de jardiniers il ya deux ans
maintenant parce que on devait le faire
pour 2020 c'était dans le cadre de
l'afrique à 20 qui était la thématique
de la france on aurait repris cette
thématique mais qu aux sanitaires on a
dû décaler et donc on se retrouve en
2021 pour faire africa mises en scènes
paysagères retraçant le continent du
nord au sud à travers six espaces
distincts
sarah la steppe sahélienne la savane
désert du kalahari et la zone du cap ces
deux ans de travail au total de
recherche de d'acquisition de
connaissances géographiques sur le
végétal pour permettre de faire la
présentation jaillir la plus exacte du
continent africain alors bien sûr il n'y
a pas tout le continent africain
intégralement qui représentait mais les
points jir important du continent ils
sont la savane il représentait la steppe
sahélienne le sahara le comédien les
plateaux de l'atlas ou encore le cas
pour le désert du kalahari eh bien tous
ces espaces qui sont mondialement connus
on essaie d amener dans une plus petite
dimension sur la ville de limoges le le
tour de l'afrique donc là on était à
hauteur du cap on revoit remonter en
fait un petit peu puisque c'est de ce
côté là c'est le kalahari qu'on
reconnaît justement par rapport aux
terres rouges cette exposition estivale
sera accompagnée d'animations et de
concerts tout au long de l'été
partons en bretagne pour terminer ce
grand jt des territoires dans les côtes
d'armor une exposition ouvre la boîte à
souvenirs et nous plonge dans la vie
d'un ménage des années 50 à cette époque
l'électroménager faisait son entrée en
force dans la vie des familles et
notamment des ménagères retour dans le
temps avec mathilde quemeneur
journalistes de la rédaction de tv au
haut débit sud la cheffe du groupe le
télégramme en bretagne
et m'inspirait torque multifonctions
l'anti mites là c'est pour faire de la
peinture éventuellement et le casque
jack lie à l'air chaud qui arrive et
puis qui sèche les cheveux
ces collectionneurs a mené pas moins de
200 objets dans les anciens locaux du
magazine le petit écho de la mode à
châtelaudren
le grand public est invité à se plonger
dans le quotidien de la ménagère des
années 50 cette exposition elle est en
lien avec les archives du petit écho de
la mode alors parfois décrié du coeur
dans lesquels on retrouve par exemple
des questions mon mari
s'occupe que de sa voiture que de moi
que dois-je faire je suis désespéré
voilà et la réponse du petit écho
s'étaient
estimez-vous heureuse madame et s'ils
s'occupent de sa voiture c'est peut-être
parce que votre intérieur n'est pas
assez bien entretenu et quand on fait
lire c'est ce genre de courrier aux
collégiens certains sont choqués de deux
des réponses qui était faite aux
lectrices et d'autres un peu moins
donc se replonger aussi dans cette dans
cette époque des années 50 c'est juste
un petit peu de piqûre de rappel sur m
la société d'aujourd'hui aussi des
pièces entières des maisons vont être
reconstitués ainsi que des moments comme
le camping est parfois les visiteurs
pourront jouer à la ménagère marianne
leconte qui elle nous propose des
installations dans lesquelles pour le
coup on pourra rentrer s'installer se
photographier et là pour le coup
manipuler quelques objets le ménage en
beauté c'est du 10 juillet à fin octobre
a chaté l'autre un retour dans les
années 50 garantie
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales de
la tnt et sur tv5 monde on se retrouve
très vite pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]